the independent medical experts the
joint committee on vaccination and
immunization
have clearly recommended that the nhs
should make sure
that the first people to be offered the
vaccine are those at
highest risk together with the people
who look after them
in practice what that means is starting
with the
over 80s who are at much higher risk of
severe outcomes from coronavirus as well
as people in care homes
together with some of the frontline
health and social care staff who are
looking after them
and then as more vaccine becomes
available we will be
in the new year extending that to many
more people
across the country in line with the jcvi
recommendations so that in turn helps
answer the question
when in that although we are the first
health service in the world to be able
to get vaccinating
supplies from the manufacturer are
phased
so the initial tranche in december is
going to enable us to get started
but the bulk of this vaccination program
either through this vaccine
or hopefully others as well that will
join it will take place
in the period january through to march
or april
for the at-risk population
the majority of the early vaccinations
will as i say be for the over-80s and
for
care home residents and since you need
two jabs with an initial injection and
then a booster
typically around 21 days apart that
means that
we've got to reserve the second dose for
the people who are getting the first
dose in december
to make sure that that second dose is
available for them
and it also means that the people who
are getting the first dose
in december will not have the full
protection from the vaccine
until they get the second dose in
january which
emphasizes the point that we need to
continue to be extremely careful
during december and into january and
then as
vaccination expands to the wider
population
that's who and that's when in terms of
how
the vaccine that has been approved for
the nhs to deploy
uh today the fisa beyond tech vaccine
has been independently shown to be
medically safe but it is
logistically complicated we have to move
it around the country
in a carefully controlled way initially
at minus 70 degrees centigrade or
thereabouts
and then there are a limited number of
further movements that we are
allowed by the regulator to make it also
comes in packs of 975 people's doses
so you can't at this point just
distribute it to
every individual gp surgery or pharmacy
as we normally would for many of the
other vaccines available
on the nhs so
the phasing of delivery the way we will
do it
is that next week around 50 hospital
hubs
across england will start offering the
vaccine
to the over 80s and to care home
staff and others identified by the jcvi
typically they may be people who were
already down to come into hospital next
week for an outpatient appointment
so if you're going to be one of those
people next week or in the
weeks that follow the hospital will get
in touch with you
you don't need to do anything about it
yourself
that will then be followed in the
subsequent weeks
with gp practices coming together in
each area
to operate local vaccination centers
and that will grow to over a thousand
places
right across england where gps will be
in touch with their at-risk patients
inviting people to come forward for
vaccination
we've had an excellent response from gps
across the nhs
wanting to participate in this program
and as the extra vaccine comes available
we'll be able to turn on more of those
gp led
clinics and then if the
mhra the independent regulator as we
expect they will
give approval for a safe way of
splitting these packs of 975 doses
then the good news is that we will be
able to start
distributing those two care homes
and then as even more vaccine becomes
available
finally we will be able to switch on
large vaccination centers across the
country
and indeed invite local community
pharmacists
probably at the beginning of january to
begin to offer vaccination
as well so in a nutshell
this is going to be a phased program we
the nhs
your gp or your hospital the nhs will
contact you
if you are ready to be offered the
vaccination